today how was your health today Mom
good I was in the gym for a little while
and that wore me out yeah I like to
complain about that how do you remain
optimistic every day about the
challenges that you face and the ups and
the downs
uh
I mean those even the alternative
yeah alternative isn't good so I just I
love life and it's a matter of uh I
think it's a matter of acceptance the
more you accept the more you are a
grateful for it your reunion with
Christopher Lloyd
[Applause]
fans got so emotional seeing that one of
the videos has more than seven million
views on Twitter okay it goes back to
the movie that there's something about
it that connects with people on every
level I'm from the future well what's
most amazing about the future is that
and it has nothing to do with me but it
has this life I mean people don't just
like it and remember it but they
celebrate it and embrace it and you get
my face tattooed on their leg and I mean
it's it's crazy but in a good way could
we ever see it being remade possibly uh
well not with me I actually had this
kind of thought if it didn't move again
I think they should do it with a girl is
Marty oh no kidding I made a different
perspective Wanna Be Good
you and Tracy are coming up on what 35
years together wedding anniversary what
has that partnership meant to you over
the years it's been an interesting life
she's smart and she loves me she's
protective and she's
uh everything yeah and the kids the kids
are getting the kids do it it's hurtful
and then doing me
the father of four is also devoted to
his foundation which is dedicated to
finding a cure for Parkinson's Disease
the non-profit is hosting the upcoming a
funny thing happened on the way to cure
Parkinson's Gala the Michael J fox
Foundation has raised 1.5 billion
dollars how do you get your brain around
that number it's so humbling I'm gonna
act you I'm like a goofball and then and
I and I and I stumbled into this
situation and so I I did my best to
seize it when you did The Good Wife and
the good fight they Incorporated your
Parkinson's Into Your Role how important
was that for you exactly people with
Parkinson's people with disabilities
they can be jerks and and I thought to
explore that would be fun so this
character they did the last man good
wife is a guy who uses his disability to
manipulate people and uh how fun that
was and then turned to be a good thing
and congratulations an Oscar coming your
way at the governor's Awards I look
around and you have so many awards
you're adding an Oscar to these walls to
these shelves how special is that
will be cool I
put it put it on the desk or something
I'm really excited about it it's it's
nice I like to tell what's my mom could
have seen it yeah yeah but it's cool
she's an angel she'll be she'll be there
with you back to back to the future it's
going to be on Broadway next year a time
machine yeah they've been in England for
a while and it's done quite well so
they're opening in Broadway are you
excited about that and do you plan to go
see it let me go see it for sure I saw
it I was supposed to see the English
correction but covet and all that stuff
we couldn't get over there and really
excited
foreign